[Music]
thank you for joining us i'm john
langler las vegas has lost another
legend
siegfried fischbacher of siegfried and
roy died overnight
he was 81 years old the duo best known
for their lavish
strip shows their rare animals and their
long residency at the mirage but
their history in las vegas goes back
even further than that
bianca holman is live outside the mirage
where they used to perform
with reaction to this passing bianca
good afternoon
good afternoon you know you can't say
las vegas without mentioning it this
dynamic duo
sick freed and roy and that's why
there's this huge statue here in front
of the mirage of the dynamic duo
they made a huge impact on the strip and
in the valley roy died last year of
covet 19 complications
and his other half siegfried passed away
last night
the two rose to fame on stage and on
film because of their combination of
illusions and wild animals using
tigers and elephants born and raised in
germany siegfried was
always drawn to magic in the late 60s
the pair created their notable act on a
cruise ship
and soon became headliners at the new
frontier here in las vegas in the 80s
as las vegas became a destination in the
90s they moved to the mirage
tourists came specifically to see the
show las vegas historians and those who
knew them personally say
their glitzy performances will have a
lasting legacy
they were pioneers well beyond magic i
don't i don't think that you would see
cirque du soleil today i'm not even
certain if you would see
lady gaga or bruno mars in las vegas i
think that that
they really set the stage for
large-scale
meaningful substantive spectacle in las
vegas
i think if you have a mount rushmore of
las vegas entertainment
they're indisputably on it
now alan feldman who knew siegfried
personally says he was a very down to
earth person and gave the person sitting
right across from him
is undivided attention siegfried was
also known for
giving donations to various k-9 units
across the state
now funeral services will be private but
there are plans for a public memorial
service
later on reporting live from near the
las vegas boulevard and spring mountain
bianca holman 8 news now